i have a bold title so it was a title to
get you in the room so it's i'm happy
that you're all here
write safer javascript what does that
mean safer
right so i'm just quickly gonna go
through
the agenda we're just gonna see
javascript vs typescript
getting to love typescript and migrating
from javascript to typescript but
i need to answer this question first
what safer
means
undefined is not a function
say someone no bugs oh
i like that it's very ambitious man
i like that let's say again
is your debugging how many people here
in the room do javascript really
very good now keep your hands up how
about typescript
okay so i don't have to convince you
really i'm just gonna make sure that the
end of the session when i say tab script
everyone let raise their hands and they
want to do that every day
so yeah that's that's that's that's the
problem
you know that right cannot read property
bar often define
or null is not an object or
you're trying to call a function cannot
reproperty value often defined that's
really common
foo is not a function um
cannot reproperty length of undefined
that's where that's that's the safer
part i'm talking about
right i'm not talking about security and
all this stuff i'm just talking about
the fact that you can
you can write code that doesn't crash um
in production so that's a runtimes error
right so we have two things
run times errors and
compile time errors right so while
you're writing your code
you you'll be able to see this with
typescript will
be able to detect that up front okay so
javascript vs typescript
javascript is yellow
you know that color right that's
javascript
typescript is blue
javascript is
whoever is doing javascript only in the
room is already doing typescript
okay because typescript is a superset of
javascript
the way i introduce typescript to teams
that we coach
i told i tell them typescript is a
documentation tool
i'm gonna show you why i'm i'm calling
it the documentation tool yeah
it looks like a programming language but
as you start using it you're gonna
realize that
it is more documentation tools
than the programming language so that
yellow thing you already or all
all of you are doing it and the blue
part
is what typescript brings on top of the
table so yeah touchscript is a super set
of javascript the way it's described on
a microsoft website is
javascript that scales
okay so small demo time
i'm just gonna take the a thing called
uh typescript
playgrounds
okay so you can follow up with you can
follow with me
uh on this one if you want
so um it's a small um
can you see this let me put it full
screen
so let me remove this so
keep in mind that what i'm about to show
you is the fact that
javascript typescript is a superset of
javascript
okay so in javascript we have class
let's say user as you can see on the
left
on the left here is typescript on the
right is javascript
the only difference between the two is
just to use tricked
so far so we're still in the the yellow
zone
you write typescript you're doing you
basically having 101 javascript on the
other side okay
that's the yellow zone and then um
you want to write to let's say a
variable
cost user
we're still in the yellow zone right
so far so good so then
you will say what is user in typescript
you can express documentation you can
express
that user
is a user
is of class type user guess what i'm
using type right
i'm using this to to document that line
i'm using that class
i'm using a class but i'm going to show
you in a few seconds that you shouldn't
be doing it you shouldn't do that
but stay with me for a second
i'm still having a kind of 101 but i
don't have this anymore
i don't see this thing here that that
typing
documentation i'm just documenting my
code
but look what's going to happen here now
i'm going to say
um user has
login which is a string
[Music]
by hiding logging here right away here
this is this is
this isn't working anymore on the other
side we still have the same translation
but this this
isn't working that won't stop your
program to work
but at least you see it right away
that's what we were talking about
compile time now if i want to fix it
i'm just gonna have to have to add a
login here that says davey
fix it we're still in the yellow zone
now i'm gonna take you to the blue zone
okay
why aren't you happy again
yeah it just asked me to give him a
default value
that's it that's what he wants which is
a good thing
now i'm gonna take you to the the blue
zone
instead of using a class i'm just gonna
use an interface
and then i don't need to if it's an
interface it's a contract
i don't need to initialize that anymore
but look left and right
on the right i only have the cost
and on the left i have
i have this interface here on the left
and only the user
translation on the right see i use an
interface
to type my my uh my
object but i don't overload the final
javascript that is
rendered so the only thing i really did
right here
i documented this documentation
okay i'm gonna show you another example
of documentation that you can do
is to say i want the user to go
toward a certain direction okay
so right away you can see that
it's not happy because you just had a
property like you will do in javascript
let me just hide that property quickly
oh well the property you just had has an
impact all the way in the chain
because people are using or they don't
expect that property but you just had
that and then in production
boom direction of whatever is undefined
okay but i want that that direction here
to come from a new or i can say
um enumeration let's say direction
okay so as you can see here
i had an enumeration and then right away
i have this magic happening here
this line that direct and then i will
just add
left
and and then right for example
okay so yeah there is a there is a
uh translation from enum to something
that looks like this
if you don't understand that part of the
cut it's okay
it's is is just they're using some
closure to create a variable and then
they encapsulate the entire thing and
then that
that gives you a way to to assign a left
and right property on an object
dynamically
so now here i can say this thing
is a direction that let's say left
but i'm still having a problem here so
what i'm gonna do just to add the
direction property
and then say this one is a direction
is of type direction okay it's just an
enum
it's documentation here i'm expressing
the fact that you can go left and right
i could have used an object
const object direction and then left and
right that will have yield the same
result
but see how you can make it
much more appealing here just gonna say
cost
you see what happened there
it's all disappeared there is no more
overload of javascript
that you're gonna you're gonna give to
your customer because that's the part
your customer will use
in their app in the final app they run
but you
in your code you express
something to make the work of your team
easier
that's that's that's the message i want
to pass here the fact that
typescript is documentation we good so
far
so let me quickly go back here
so getting to love typescript
i'm gonna take something quickly here
for you
so i have this function set value
when i say um set value i'm going to
receive this value and i say if
value var real value and then value here
so if i call it can you can you all see
this
good if i call set value
and i do this and then i say
set value to be
yeah here i actually need to say this
and then this that would probably be
much
realistic and then here i say
devi and then here i say
and number 12.
guess what is happening here
what do you think is going to be yield
here on line 9
there is so yeah it that doesn't work
that won't work
yeah so see now we're already talking
about
the fact that hosting is gonna be in
into play here it's gonna enter into
play here
right so there is already kind of
understanding javascript but as well
understanding the fact that
are we going to enter here is this code
is is written in a sense like
this can enter here first line
nine is it going to enter here
no and then the two two other cases we
enter but
regardless we're gonna have undefined
here
and then
tv and then 12. okay but that
i'm gonna have to open the code source
and then start making sense
of what you're trying to do
i can make it much easier by saying
value
could be either a string
or number
see by doing those these two already
are solved but how about this part
i can communicate via documentation
that this part is sometime
optional i'm just documenting my code
that's all i'm doing okay
so once you you reach that part there's
some magic that's gonna happen here and
then
yeah you can use a good let here that
will make your life much easier but if
you do so
you see the scope gonna enter and play
and that's not typescript that is just
raw javascript
so let me just move it here then it
doesn't crash
and then i can i can set the value
right here okay
now it's not over because i still need
to do something that looks like
what is the possible return value
because if you give me a string or
number
i can also have as return value a string
and a number
i'm just expressing what my code
is supposed to do but here is the thing
the day the day i discover what i'm
about to show you
i discovered that in touchscript and i
was like there is no way i'm doing
javascript again
i'm going to show you that line of code
i was here and i said value
dot because i already said string or
number
when i say value dot i only get
to string or value right
but then one step further i realized
that
if i have an if condition like this one
and i can say type of
value is equal
let's say string now
inside here when i say value dot
that at this moment my brain just did
there is no way you're not doing
typescript in your life
just that because
just with that all the screen that's
shown you
function doesn't exist and what have
disappeared entirely
yeah some some cases won't work entirely
but
this gives you what i'm trying to show
you okay
so i can go much further i'm happy to
talk about it
right after so what i'm saying here
typescript is a documentation tool
it is a documentation tool so the next
question will be
if you had if you have a huge javascript
project how can you go from javascript
to typescript
there are three steps three
the first one is super easy
just make it work you know what i mean
here
you take you generate a ts config file
cs config which is a typescript
configuration
and then you add set implicit any which
is just a property in your ts config
you just put it at false
what does that mean it means any
javascript it just make sure that you're
still in the
yellow zone right that's it that's all
it does
it doesn't yell at you but typescript is
already there
so you're still in your javascript
project
not typescript touchscript is just
behind
watching everything at first then
you rename all your js file to
ts or tsx if you're using a react and
then
pre-act and all this tool that's it
don't don't don't force that onto your
team just just do this
they won't they won't see it yeah
they will see the ts thing right but for
them
that won't really change in terms of the
code they write every day
right that's one step second one
now be explicit
don't ch turn the any
to instead instead of first putting that
true you know what's going to happen
it will just put some red line between
the things that are that don't have
types
that's it that's all it's going to do
everything is still okay all right you
can put that on your teammates
they'll be okay they will just be like
we have new red flags what is happening
here
then you tell them let's just
take all the the types the command types
like if you're on a node project just do
a npm install at type node
just do that this is a common type it's
they're all known
once they're in your project most of the
red thing
will will just vanish because it will
recognize that
no typing or it's it's there that's it
well don't do that in two days just you
do the first step
then you wait three months then you do
this part okay
and then you add typing for third-party
tools like a library you're using and
stuff like that you had typing for that
okay now that part
if you leave that for a few months i'm
not kidding
because the third part is where you get
you get into war
the third part is be straight means that
you just go in the the typescript config
file and then you put
strict to true so what does that mean it
means that
your project isn't working anymore
it just means that now we're gonna have
to type everything you're gonna have to
express every single line of code
in your application that's what it means
okay i want i i have i have a repo for
you
i have a repo for you where i have those
three steps it's in the
resource part and um you can just check
the
three steps okay with that
i hope that you'll be able to play with
touchscript a little bit more
i'm gonna be outside answering questions
if you want to
to drink typescript i'll be here if you
want to
think typescript with react i'm gonna
help touchscript with vue.js i'm gonna
help
i know those things typescript with
angular i'm not i'm not gonna help
because it's already there
so just go and do it and
voila questions
one question of the day is someone at
the back of the room
who had the question
hi uh thank you for your presentation
yeah
i would like to know there is a lot of
libraries that don't have types for
uh for type for typescript so
i would like to know how you can
generate this or
uh yeah so you have you have a uh tools
that can basically scan those
those um um library and then generate
generics
typing for them that's going to
facilitate the work but you have a
um on github there is a github repo
and defined type something like that
where you're going to
mostly find uh whatever you need in 2012
13 14 that typescript was a nightmare
guess what today it's it's top of the
game on top of the game literally
from the react team to the view team
they all use that
to write safer code today
but you have to that can generate types
for you
it's recorded but we don't know your
name just your voice
so exit is this way if you are in russia
people